من عمان ينضم الينا السيد عمار عمار
المتحدث الاقليمي باسم اليونيسف اهلا بك
سيد عمار اذا الاطفال في غزه لا يحصلون
على 90 في المئه من حاجاتهم الطبيعيه
للمياه طبعا هذا بالاضافه الى الوضع
الانساني الصحي الامني الخطير للغايه في
غزه ما مدى قتامه الصوره التي ترصدها في
اليونيسيف بخصوص وضع الاطفال في
غزه يعني وضع لا يمكن الا ان نصفه بانه
كارثي لانه مع القصف المتواصل والعدد
الكبير من القتل خاصه بين الاطفال والجرحى
كمان عم نشوف انه الوضع الانساني فيما
يتعلق بالوضع الصحي والوضع الغذائي وعلى
راسهم ايضا الوضع فيما يتعلق بالمياه
الصالحه للشرب والصرف الصحي ممكن تزيد
نسبه الوفيات بين الاطفال ممكن تتجاوز
العدد الذي يسقط قريبا من من بسبب القصف
وهذه يعني ممكن يسبب حيله كثير كبيره يعني
من من الماسات الانسانيه التي لم يسبق لها
مثيل بعت ليس فقط في في فلسطين وغزه وانما
ايضا على صعيد العالم فبالتالي اذا ننظر
حاليا تقريبا فيما يتعلق بالنازحين الجدد
من الاطفال لا يحصلوا الا على 13% من
الاحتياجات اليوميه يعني 1.5 الى 2 لتر
باليوم بينما المعايير الدنيه خلال خلال
الازمات هي 15 لتر وهذا 2 لتر تستخدم في
جميع نواحي الحياه من ضمن الاكل والتنظيف
والنظافه الشخصيه والشرب وما الى هنالك
فبالتالي كل هذه العوامل المشتركه حتدي
الى الى الى انه تزداد الامراض واذا اضفنا
الى ذلك فيما يتعلق بال العدد الكبير من
الاطفال النازحين ويلي تشاركوا تقريبا 700
شخص تشاركونا حمام واحد فيما يتعلق
ب الاستحمام ايضا لا توجد مرافق للاستحمام
وخاصه اذا اخذنا انه الاطفال الموجودين في
خارج مراكز و فبالتالي ممكن ان يلجوا الى
وسائل بديله يلي هي انه يضطروا انه
يستخدموا
المرافق لا توجد مرافق للصرف الصحي ولا
المياه فبالتالي ممكن هيدا انه يزيد من
انتقال الامراض وعم نشوف حاليا انه نسبه
الامراض اللي عم تنتقل نتيجه المياه الغير
صالحه للشرب كثير كبيره منها العدوه
التنفسيه الحاده تقريبا 120 الف طفل
بالاضافه الى الاسهالات المزمنه بالاضافه
الى ذلك الجفاف يل تضع حياه الاطفال في
خطر كثير
متزايد وفي ضوء هذه الاوضاع الكارثيه هل
هناك اي جهود تبذلها المنظمات الامميه
لمساعده اطفال
غزه طبعا نحن عم نقوم مع الشركاء
بتوفير الفيول لتشغيل الابار محت تحليه
المياه اداره النفيات والصرف الصحي ايضا
توفير المياه الصالحه للشرب من خلال
العبوات
المعباه واضافه الى توزيع المواد النظافه
الشخصيه كثير مهمه لحتى منع انتقال
الامراض لكن كل هي الامور تبقى غير كافيه
بسبب الاحتياجات الانسانيه الهائله ولحتى
نحن نقدر بالفعل نتفادى وضع او كارثه
الصحيه عامه يجب انه يكون هناك ادخال
للمواد اللازمه مثل المولدات اللازمه
لتشغيل لتشغيل محطات المياه والصرف الصحي
الحيويه جنبا الى جنب مع الانابيب
البلاستيكيه الضروريه لاجراءات الاصلاحات
المؤقته ومواد البناء اللازمه ايضا ل
لحلول الصرف الصحي السريعه وهيدي كل
المواد موجوده عندنا نحن بمعبر فرق رفع
لكن لا يمكن لهذه الامدادات الاساسيه
الدخول الى قطاع غزه للاسف بسبب القيود
المفروضه على الوصول اليه وهذه الا
الامدادات كثير ضروريه وحيويه لاستعاده
الخدمات الدنيا للمياه للمياه لصرف الصحي
التي تعد اساسيه لبقاء السكان والاطفال
فبالتالي نحن بنطالب وما زلنا نطالب من
خلال لقاءاتنا مع الدول المؤثره ومع جمعيه
الافريقا انه تعطى الاولويه في هذا الجانب
الى هذه المواد والا انه حنشوف الوضع
الصحي حيكون على كرته صحيه عامه وخاصه مع
دخول الامطار حاليا يعني شفنا من اسبوعين
الوضع الكارتي لما كان هناك هطول للامطار
واعتقد انه هناك ايضا هطول الاطار خلال
اليومين القادمين فهذا ح يعني ماسات كثير
كبيره وحنشوف انتشار كثير كبير للامراض
بشكل لم يسبق له مثيل في قطاع غزه التي
ستضع حياه عشرات الالاف من الاطفال في خطر
مباشر استمرار ض اتخذ اجراءات ضروريه
عاجله مثل
ماذا دخول المواد تفض نا عننا هيدي كثير
اساسيه لانه بدوننا ما ممكن نستعيد توفير
الخدمات الاساسيه الدنيا عم نحكي مش نحن
العليا الدنيا فيما يتعلق بتوفير المياه
الصالحه للشرب بشكل كافي وايضا خدمات
استعاده الخدمات الصرف الصحي الاساسيه
لانه مع اختلاطها مع مياه الامطار حيكون
في في كرثه صحيه عامه وطبعا فيما يتعلق
بادخال الفيول كمان الفيول كثير مهم انه
تزيد كميات الفيول اللي عم تدخل لنقدر
نزيد من ايصال المياه الى المولدات التي
تعمل على استخراج المياه من الابار
الجوفيه وايضا على زياده قدره محطات
التحليات المياه لحتى نوفر مياه اضافيه
للسكان تتجاوز الان يلي هي فقط 13% مما
يجب ان يحصل عليه الفرد الواحد وخاصه بين
النازحين الجدد يلي هم مش موجودين في
اماكن اماكن غير غير صالحه للعيش للاسف
الشديد واثنين اذا ب نمكن كمان فيما يتعلق
بالبيئه العمليات على الارض مع استمرار
القصف ما فيها المنظمات الدوليه تقدر توصل
على كل الاماكن لحتى تقوم الاصلاحات
اللازمه
وتوفير المساعدات اللازمه
فهذا اهم اجراء قد يستفيد منه الاطفال
ويحتاجه الان هو وقف القتال من الاساس لكن
في حال ما اذا استمر الوضع على ما هو عليه
ما الذي سيعني ذلك بالنسبه
لاطفال غزه الذين مازالوا احياء ولم
تقتلهم حتى الان
اسرائيل بالضبط وهذا اللي افضلنا فيه نحن
فيما يتعلق انه سوف ننظر الى ماساه
انسانيه فيما يتعلق انه العدد كبير من
الاطفال سيفقدون حياتهم نتيجه الاوضاع
الانسانيه المتعلقه
بالامراض نقص الغذاء وايضا الامراض
المنقوله عبر المياه تتجاوز بكثير القصف
الذي حتى الان ادى الى مقتل الالاف من
الاطفال فحك امام ماساه اكبر من التي
نراها حاليا فيما يتعلق باطفال غزه
فبالتالي نحن بنجع بشدد على الرساله
الاسيه اللي تفضلتي عنا عليها ونحن من ضمن
لقاءاتنا مع وفي مجلس الامن من ضمن منظومه
الامم المتحده ومع الدول المؤثره انه وقف
اطلاق النار هو من الاشياء الاساسيه اللي
ما زلنا ننادي فيها من اليوم الاول لانه
لا مزيد لا لا حل بوقف قتل الاطفال الا
وقف اطلاق النار اشكرك جزيل الشكر السيد
عمار عمار المتحدث الاقليمي باسمي
اليونيسف من عمان